we're very proud to recognize today haji
me cosine
I was sponsored from one Japanese
company and I like that company so I
didn't think about moving to any other
country companies but once you get
educated and you see things differently
before that I was there on operation
side of the business kind of micro point
of view and and after 12 years in
business I changed really I could see
total picture that's what the change was
to me in terms of the events that we're
doing for business school it's a monthly
happy where you can have drinks and chat
each other you know have fun doing
things for the club is fun because I see
a lot of people from Colombia they are
great yeah I want to be you know
listening to them I won't be learning
from them I have this benefit of being
outside titled country so that when
president Bollinger come you know we
have this reception he spent a lot of
time with us we invite professor Jeffrey
Sachs odinga ball came to Japan spend a
lot of time with us so I think being in
the global community has somebody
so the first time I hear about this
mellow I feel like why me I didn't do
anything as I was getting medals and in
front my family I feel great